уряд затвердив законопроект який змінює
підходи до оплати здобуття вищої освіти
за ним кількість місць на бюджеті
скорочується натомість з'являється така
опція як державний грант коли вступнику
пропонують співфінансувати своє навчання
у Міністерстві освіти сподіваються що ці
новації запрацюють уже цього року і
наголошують що ці зміни не стосуються
тих хто має пільги кореспонденткатсн
Інна боднер проаналізувала нову
законодавчу ініціативу разом із
міністром освіти і зі
вступниками у цьому класі жменька
одинадцятикласників які зараз
наполегливо готуються до
мультипредметного тесту і плюс-мінус
розуміють де будуть вчитися і як
контракт бюджет контракт контракт у
цьому році до класичного розуміння
бюджет і контракт додається нове поняття
державний грант цю структуру
фінансування вищої освіти уже затвердив
уряд і в Міністерстві освіти
сподіваються що і парламент підтримає і
запрацює це все уже у цьому навчальному
році наше
завдання забезпечуючи цю соціальну
складову державного
фінансування на здобуття вищої освіти
зробити її більш справедливою тобто у
нас немає чорно-білої моделі у нас єсть
градації в залежності від своїх
результатів ти все одно отримуєш певний
рівень державної підтримки ось це
Маргарита і Георгій вони наполегливо
готуються до нмт додатко займається щоб
отримати високі бали і вже знають ким
хочуть бути ось маргарито Ким ти хочеш
бути філологинею і якщо буде державне
замовлення на філологів то Маргарита з
своїми високими балами зможе вчитися
просто на бюджеті і гарантовано матиме
робоче місце в державному секторі Марго
А мені обов'язково там Працювати от на
це нам відповів міністр що ж провчившись
2-т роки він розуміє що він ну з якихось
причин неправильно обрав професію він ві
не готовий три роки працювати в цій
професії в інтересах держави в державній
сфері він може відмовитися від
подальшого навчання державного
замовлення і не повертаючи кошти перейти
на контракт а от Георгій хоче бути
журналістом і якщо державі не потрібна
така величезна армія журналістів то
Георгій може скористатися таким поняттям
як державний грант він залежить від
рівня як ти складеш нмт чим Вищий бал на
нмт тим більший вищий державний грант ви
дивитесь що у нас на ринку ваша
спеціальність журналіст ви дивитесь
отримали грант наприклад 45 000 і
приймаєте рішення університет інститут
журналістики Київського національного
університету 65 000 10 000 на рік я
дофінансую
щоб навчаться тут Ну можливо так
дофінансовую не
дофінансую Ось за 35 000 я зможу
навчатися наприклад там в Львівському
Франка або в каразя А якщо нема грошей
дофінансовувати інструмент пільгового
кредитування коли ти можеш взяти
пільговий кредит довготривалий і
дофінансувати за рахунок кредиту своє
навчання в університеті і завдяки от
такій системі коли крім класичного
бюджету ще й з'явиться таке поняття як
державний грант у Міністерстві освіти
сподіваються що державну підтримку
фінансову під час здобуття вищої освіти
зможуть отримувати не 40% як зараз
вступників а 70 Інна бодна Роман сищенко
Іван Павлович ТСН 1+1 марафон єдині
новини